alain ferrand bonjour et merci d'être
avec nous en ligne ce matin alors cet
exemple et il isolé ou est-ce que vous
voyez beaucoup de cas comme celui ci au
sein de l'observatoire international des
prisons
alors il ya en fait il ya deux il ya
deux captures dans votre question de la
première c est ce qu on voit beaucoup de
personnes qui sont soumises à des
conditions de détention qui mériteraient
ou qui justifierait une indemnisation et
oui évidemment en dépit de la baisse de
la population carcérale suite à la crise
du coc vie dans nos jours on complète
aujourd'hui nous remonter de 7,7 des
taux d'occupation et vous avez par
exemple aujourd'hui plus de 20000
personnes détenues qui sont détenus dans
des établissements qui sont surpeuplés à
plus de 150%
donc évidemment qu'il ya un nombre
important de personnes détenues qui
pourrait aujourd'hui faire des demandes
mais en tout cas nous on constate
effectivement beaucoup de personnes
sûrement des situations qui justifierait
des demandes d'indemnisation ensuite la
question qui se pose c'est de savoir si
deux fêté dans la réalité beaucoup de
demandes sont déposées et ça c'est pas
contre si vous voulez les différences
entre le nombre de personnes qui
pourraient demander des personnes qui
demandent pour différentes raisons et
notamment parce que certaines personnes
détenues créneau craignent des mesures
de représailles chez engage les
procédures contre leurs conditions de
détention
alors les conditions de détention sont
discutées depuis nombre d'années où se
situe la france par rapport aux autres
pays européens
ben on aide on est au sein du conseil de
l'europe dans le feuilleton bd des pays
de tête sur le port de la surpopulation
carcérale et on a si vous voulez depuis
une trentaine d'années une quarantaine
d'années considérablement étendu le parc
carcéral français en manque de place
puisque on entend beaucoup dans les
discours qui manquent qu'on manque de
places en nombre de places on sort n'a
jamais autant construit que au cours des
trente dernières années le parc carcéral
en nombre de places a doublé depuis le
début des années 80 et pour autant cette
augmentation sans fin de deux les
capacités de 2 places n'a pas permis
d'absorber la surpopulation qui croient
à la même vie un plus vite et avec une
courbe équivalente mais les plus
importantes donc c'est un problème
important on je répète on est un pays au
sein du conseil de l'europe où la
surpopulation il a plu
or tentes et c'est un problème qu'on
n'arrive pas à endiguer par l'option
politique été choisi jusqu'à présent de
construire construire construire alors
pas à cette place
les cellules également sont dans de
mauvaises conditions pourquoi les
prisons ne sont pas rénovés
alors il ya deux choses dont les
conditions de vie en cellule sans
effectivement terrible et évidemment les
la situation est pire encore dans les
maisons d'arrêt parce que c'est dans les
maisons d'arrêt que se consacrent
concentre la surpopulation dans la
situation qui a conduit à la
condamnation de la france là les
personnes était un détenu entre 4 et 5 4
et 5 dans une cellule de seize mètres
carrés en sachant que toulouse est pour
maison d'arrêt comme il ya très peu
d'offres de travail très peu d'offres
d'activité etc
les gens passent l'essentiel de leur
journée enfermé dans la cellule
certaines passent plus de 20 heures par
jours enfermés dans leur cellule tant
imaginez que vous soyez enfermé avec
quatre autres personnes 20 heures par
jour parfois des années dans une cellule
de 2,16 mètres carrés et à cela s'ajoute
la vétusté et c'est alors sur la
question de pourquoi est ce que ses
conditions de détention sont pas
améliorées et notamment vont me parler
du problème de l'entretien alors il ya
aujourd'hui des chiffres qui sont qui
sont publiés et compris par le
gouvernement enfin ils établissent
clairement qu' il ya un
sous-investissement dans le dans
l'investissement c'est des raisons
financières en fait c'est que
l'essentiel des budgets qui sont alloués
au parc carcéral sont absorbés par la
construction de nouvelles places de
prison
et donc si vous voulez pendant que la
france construit de nouvelles places
elle n'a pas l'argent pour entretenir
celles existantes déjà
donc vous avez en plus un truc
complètement d'ayant que des places se
construisent mais faute d'entretien
deviennent très rapidement totalement et
ligue étudie des projets en cours
justement pour recourir à ce problème
bah écoutez nous la seule des projets en
cours n'ont pas vraiment enfin il ya on
nous annonçait encore la construction de
places de prison mais je répète que
c'est une solution qui n'en est pas une
et que plus il ya de place plus on
remplit la seule solution pour nous
c'est c'est de baisser la population
carcérale est donc d'insister sur tous
les mécanismes de prévention qui sont
ces types de réduire l'ampleur en prison
agir sur la durée des peines enfin sur
sur tous les leviers d'une politique
réductionniste et puis parure développer
évidemment les alternatives à la
détention
merci beaucoup nicolas ferran d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes responsable du pôle
contentieux à l'observatoire
international des prisons